you've been acting for over 40 years
your first project your first appearance
on screen was an educational film calls
a lot I we have no one
your parents slap ya huh I don't know
what you're talking a lot of these shows
and that was weeks ago weeks ago I mean
the mood for March now you bring us in
the air you think he's gonna see this
coming
acting over 40 years your first film was
an educational film for school systems
called Linda's film on menstruation
[Laughter]
let's take a look at this guy Johnny do
you notice anything different about me
today No
you sure you got Rouge on so what's so
different about you I got my first
period today
you might be the most clueless guy how
did that happen it goes under the
category of no good deed goes unpunished
my friend George I can who eventually
became a lawyer over Warner's and all
that he back in the day he went my
girlfriend wants to do a film for the
New York public school system she's
going to try to sell it that
administration will you do this for me
if I curse well you can just cut it out
can you do that here yeah said oh right
yeah the mother they they they put this
thing up now it's been up for a couple
of years and you know and it's on
YouTube now oh man everybody's watching
it on YouTube and now we just made it
worse
I have a question are they gonna get
money from that now that it's aired I
don't know how that works I don't think
so you know what no I don't think they
do George I can I'm gonna hunt you death
money from that
you